- [Narrator] What I
wanna do in this video is
think about how exchange
rates can affect trade,
and actually we can even
think a little bit about
how they might be able
to affect each other,
although we'll go into
a lot more depth in that
in future videos.
So let's just imagine a
situation where the Chinese Yuan,
the Chinese Yuan depreciates
versus the dollar,
depreciates versus the
US dollar to be clear,
US dollar.
To visualize what we're talking about,
let's draw the supply and demand,
or the exchange market
for the Chinese Yuan.
So our horizontal axis would be quantity,
quantity of Yuan,
and then our vertical axis
would be the price of a Yuan
in terms of dollars,
so dollars per Yuan.
And we've seen this before.
This right here would
be the supply of Yuan,
so these would be the
people who are holding Yuan
but might be willing to
exchange them into dollars,
and then this would be
the demand for Yuan,
these are the people
who are holding dollars
who might be interested in
exchanging them for Yuan.
There will be some
equilibrium exchange rate,
let's call that E sub 1,
and let's call this,
it's an equilibrium
quantity per time period,
let's say call that Q sub 1.
And just to be clear, this is
our supply curve for the Yuan,
and this is our demand curve for the Yuan.
So a situation where the
Chinese Yuan depreciates
versus the dollar.
There is two ways really
that that could happen.
One, you could have
the demand for the Yuan
shift to the left, or you
could have the supply of Yuan
shift to the right.
The demand shifting to the
left would mean for some reason
people who hold dollars are
less interested in getting Yuan,
and supply shifting to
the right would mean
people who hold Yuan are all of a sudden
more interested in getting dollars.
So let's just do the latter one.
So let's say the supply
shifts to the right.
I just want a scenario where we have
the Chinese Yuan depreciating
against the US dollar.
And so you see very clearly in this world,
if our demand does not shift,
we get to this next equilibrium
exchange rate, E sub 2,
and there's also a different
equilibrium quantity.
But you can see the Chinese
Yuan has depreciated
versus the dollar.
If E sub 1, maybe E sub 1 is
15 cents per Chinese Yuan,
and maybe E sub 2 is 10
cents per Chinese Yuan.
But now that we understand
and we can visualize
what we're talking about,
what would be the impact on trade.
I'm gonna think about it in two ways.
What is going to happen in China,
let's think about China first.
So in China, or we're
gonna be thinking about
the Chinese consumers.
Well Chinese consumers, they hold Yuan,
and they might buy some American goods.
What would happen to the
cost of those American goods?
Well assuming that the American suppliers
offer their products in a fixed
dollar price, so let's say
you are General Motors,
an American car company,
and there's a car that's
manufactured in the United States
and it costs $20,000.
Well in a world where the
Chinese Yuan depreciates
versus the dollar, the
amount of Yuan to equal
20,000 US dollars has now increased.
You need more Yuan per dollar,
because you're in a world where there is
fewer dollars per Yuan.
So American goods,
American goods,
more expensive in China,
expensive in China.
And so what might that do to the behavior,
how might people decide
to trade off between
American and Chinese, let's
say in this example, cars.
Well if American goods,
and in this example, cars
become relatively more expensive,
then they're likely to
buy fewer American cars.
So if we're talking about
all American products,
we could say American,
American imports into China,
into China,
will go down, because they're going to be
relatively more expensive.
Now what about in the United States,
in the United States,
what is going to happen.
Well, assuming the Chinese goods
are offered by the supplier
at a fixed Yuan price,
well now you need fewer dollars per Yuan.
So Chinese goods,
Chinese goods,
are going to be less expensive,
less expensive,
to American buyers,
so less expensive in the US,
'cause each dollar is gonna buy more Yuan
and assuming that the goods
all have a fixed price in Yuan,
and so you could say Chinese imports into,
imports into the US are going to go up.
And what's interesting
is that you might have
a little bit of a negative
self-correcting feedback loop,
because what's likely to happen if
American imports into China go down.
Well that means that fewer
Chinese folks are going to be
interested in converting
their Yuan into US dollars
in order to buy goods,
because they're not buying
as many American goods,
and so that might have the effect of
shifting the supply
curve back to the left.
Similarly, in a world where
Chinese imports to the
United States go up,
well now all of a sudden
more Americans will be
interested in converting
their dollars into Yuan,
and so that might shift the
demand curve to the right.
So that might, either of
these could have the effect of
maybe helping the Chinese
Yuan appreciate a bit.
Now in previous videos, we've talked about
many factors that could shift
the supply or demand curve
for a currency to the right or left,
but it would be interesting to think about
what would be the effects
of interest rate changes
in each country.
Now we can link it not just to
what would happen to the
supply and demand curve,
but we could think about
how that might affect trade.
Let's imagine a situation
where the US government,
government, increases borrowing,
and we've talked about
this in previous videos.
That will likely lead to
increased interest rates,
'cause you have a big borrower here,
you could even have a crowding out effect
because of the increased interest rates,
fewer private borrowers
in the US might borrow,
but this would increase
likely, doesn't always,
increase interest rates,
interest rates,
in the US.
Now if you have increased rates in the US,
what might happen for folks in China.
Well they might say hey,
we are more interested in
holding dollars 'cause we could,
in a dollar bank account,
all of a sudden we get more interest.
So that could have the
effect that we saw earlier,
where it could say,
hey more Yuan holders are interested in
converting into the US dollars,
so it would shift the
supply of Yuan to the right,
which would have the impact of
depreciating the Chinese Yuan,
which is where we started this video.
So you could see something like
the US government borrowing,
which increases interest rates,
could actually have an impact on trade.
It could actually make American goods
less competitive in China,
and Chinese goods more
competitive in the United States.
And I just did a scenario
where the supply curve
shifts to the right,
but you could also
imagine a situation where
government borrowing increasing
the interest rate in the United States
could even change the demand curve.
Remember, the demand curve's
gonna be determined by
the sentiment from dollar holders,
and how much they wanna
convert to the Yuan.
But if interest rates in
the United States go up,
well now they might say hey,
I might wanna save in the
United States as opposed to
investing in China or
converting my money to Yuan,
and saving in Chinese bank accounts.
So I'll leave you there.
The big thing to appreciate here is that
exchange rates and trade are very linked,
and that things like government borrowing
can affect interest rates,
which can affect exchange rates,
which can affect trade.